mon café il est où mon café
ça va super bien parce qu'effectivement
je vous explique je suis le nouveau
stagiaire de Salut les Terriens enfin
stagiaire c'est la bidouille qui a
trouvé Thierry pour m'embaucher dans
cette entreprise dans la conjoncture
actuelle voilà alors
merci beaucoup pour l'augmentation
Thierry parce que j'ai été augmenté
réévalué financièrement d'une semaine
sur l'autre ça c'est cool à maintenant
je suis le reposcesseur de ticket resto
d'une valeur de 4,90 € c'est pas de la
merde ce qui nous fait toujours 1 euro
de plus à rajouter pour la formule kebab
frites plus qu'un net si cher attirer
Ardisson ici présent
[Applaudissements]
à la suite de la conférence de rédaction
le retour de Stéphane Guillon oui qui a
été très très bien reçu par les
téléspectateurs et ça fait plaisir
beaucoup de lettres d'amour et parmi
elles quelques lettres de sympathisants
de Marine Le Pen
agrémenté d'une petite balle de revolver
à l'intérieur merci beaucoup maintenant
on peut ouvrir une armurerie alors
[Applaudissements]
on a un très beau plateau Thierry ce
soir hein
ça fait plaisir en plus vous avez tous
les trois un point commun vous êtes tous
Juifs enfin sauf Véronique et Manu
bah du coup il y a que vous Patrick
voilà
en tout cas Véronique Sanson je suis
très fier d'être à vos côtés parce que
je vous le dis voilà dans notre famille
on vous aime beaucoup vous savez qu'à
cause de vous mon deuxième prénom c'est
Véronique
et encore j'ai eu de la chance parce que
ma sœur son deuxième prénom c'est besoin
de personne alors
[Applaudissements]
Véronique vous a été marié avec Pierre
Palmade c'était un très très beau
mariage c'était pas mon sketch préféré
de Pierre je préfère le Scrabble ou le
colonel mais c'était très très beau
alors
mesdames et messieurs maintenant je suis
ici pour vous poser les questions trop
con que Thierry n'a pas voulu vous poser
Manu vous avez tourné avec Joey Starr et
Fabrice Luchini alors est-ce que c'est
vrai que il y en a un quand tu
l'emmerdes il te met son point sur la
gueule et l'autre il parle pas en trois
heures
Véronique Sanson votre première partie
elle Olympia ça va être votre fils
Christopher Stills alors du coup est-ce
que c'est pour lui faire plaisir ou pour
éviter de payer une baby-sitter comment
ça se passe
et dernière question
[Musique]
Patrick Timsit vous dites que vous aimez
faire rire avec ce qui fait mal du coup
j'attends avec impatience votre sketch
sur la sodomie bonne soirée je présente
le stagiaire dans Salut les Terriens
cette saison voilà je suis le seul à
Canal+ à World dans mon contrat une
clause qui m'autorise à me [__] de la
gueule de tirer Ardisson je peux me
moquer de tout enfin sauf ce de son
physique son âge le cannabis sa femme
ses enfants et son poignet de force
voilà mais sinon j'écarte blanche vous
êtes sûr je peux pas faire de Vannes sur
le poignée de force parce que c'est vrai
qu'on fait pas de muscu et pas de moto
c'est c'est ridicule alors on enchaîne
petit débrie rapide quand même sur
l'émission de la semaine dernière
Thierry je vous le dis je suis très très
déçu parce que la semaine dernière on a
reçu Véronique Sanson oui moi je me suis
vraiment cassé le cul pour lui faire une
loge aux petits oignons voilà
franchement ce serait cru chez Nicolas
non mais c'est vrai je me voilà 82
caisses ça m'a coûté trois séances
d'océans cette connerie et la meuf elle
a touché rien du tout par contre elle
nous a déglingué le stock de San
Pellegrino
du coup par contre avec le stock que
j'ai on peut recevoir Renault quand vous
voulez cette semaine c'est un très très
beau plateau Thierry félicitations
Emmanuel Petit qui vient nous voir pour
son livre front tireur alors comme vous
l'avez demandé j'ai fait le résumé de
son livre voilà il est juste là
c'est bien résumé isabelle Mergault qui
vient de voir pour sa pièce de théâtre
qui revient Isabelle c'est bien parce
que c'est attiré le public jeune au
théâtre puisqu'elle jouait avec Sylvie
Vartan bien joué Philippe Etchebest
pas de vanne sur Philippe Etchebest non
tu peux
non j'ai envie de rester en vie
gratte une piémontaise il se fait
défoncer moi si je fais une boulette moi
j'ai envie de voir grandir mes gosses à
la limite je préfère m'en prendre à
Claude Bartolone bah oui quand même je
veux dire entre un contrôle fiscal et me
retrouver un truc à te plonge je sais
pas le choix il est vite fait vous
connaissez la date pleine d'argent n'est
pas mortel peut-être mais plaît ouverte
peut s'infecter d'ailleurs Claude
bartholone vous connaissez déjà un peu
bien placé et tout
ce que je vous explique en fait je
recherche un logement je vis dans un 9
m2 c'est la galère il était dans quelles
circonscription Thierry avant que le
bartolin c'est le roi du 9 3 vous
emmerdez pas ça va
vous savez pas ce que vous loupez
maintenant mesdames et messieurs je suis
ici pour vous poser les questions trop
con que Thierry n'a pas voulu vous poser
on va commencer avec Isabelle Mergault
Isabelle vous jouez votre pièce avec
Sylvie Vartan au Théâtre des Variétés
qui a deux pas du musée Grévin c'est
pour que Sylvie Vartan puisse rentrer
plus vite chez elle
Claude bartholone ça vous embête pas
d'être le seul à ne pas pouvoir dormir
l'Assemblée nationale
à l'Assemblée nationale ce sont des
vieux qui dorment sur des banquettes
enveloppes rouges du coup Michel Drucker
il nous a fait un procès ou pas encore
Emmanuel Petit vous êtes connus pour
être l'écorché vif du football français
vous savez que si vous aviez été dans la
chanson française vous auriez été
Francis Lalanne vous avez eu la chance
Philippe Etchebest vous connaissez
l'adage avec les humoristes femmes qui
rient à moitié dans son lit du coup pour
les cuisiniers c'est quoi ces femmes
repu à moitié dans son
je vais y aller merci beaucoup
ça va bien ça va c'est un peu long le
café mais bon c'est cool je me présente
je m'appelle Tom villa je suis le
stagiaire de Salut les Terriens alors
Thierry sans vouloir être chiant je
viens d'apprendre que je suis moins bien
payé que les trois mannequins qui sont
au premier rang
alors ça veut dire qu'applaudir ça vaut
plus que d'écrire des blagues c'est ça
le j'ai rien contre vous les filles
parce que c'est vrai que le chauffeur de
salle il demande soit d'applaudir soit
de rigoler et une fois sur deux vous
inversez donc
[Applaudissements]
c'est extraordinaire quand même le monde
de la télévision on arrive à faire
croire aux gens que le samedi soir il y
a 4 mannequins sublimes qui s'appellent
et qui disent hey les filles si on
allait voir Salut les Terriens sur un
banc en bois pourri pendant deux heures
c'est extraordinaire
petit bilan de la semaine dernière très
très bonne audiences félicitations
Thierry 1 million 200000 téléspectateurs
bravo si je peux me permettre ça fait
toujours 65 millions qui s'en battent
les couilles un autre débat et
d'ailleurs sur Twitter isabelle Mergault
a marqué les esprits la semaine dernière
ce qui était en petite nuisette sexy
alors je rappelle juste là on est dans
un studio avec des lumières il fait
chaud c'est la fête mais faut savoir que
dehors c'est la pleine Saint-Denis il y
a le périph le début de l'autoroute A1
si quelqu'un a des nouvelles d'Isabelle
Mergault envoyez-nous un message parce
que nous on a aucune nouvelle voilà
aujourd'hui les invités Ariane Brodier
alors Ariane vous dit tout le temps sur
les réseaux sociaux vous cherchez un mec
non j'en cherche plusieurs parce que
[Applaudissements]
la semaine dernière on se réveille
Claude Bartolone à une semaine près ton
mec qui était Président de l'Assemblée
nationale non mais en plus il nous l'a
dit que le Bartolone moi chercher une
blonde bien gaulée au PS il y a des
troncs blancs donc c'est con quand même
Chris marquez c'est l'un des jurys de
Danse avec les stars Thierry ou plutôt
le titre ça devrait être danse avec des
mecs que j'ai déjà vu quelque part mais
je me souviens plus dans quoi et non
alors Chris il est chorégraphe et ça
c'est génial moi j'ai un excellent prof
de de danse en boîte de nuit c'est le
whisky coca
au bout de 8 verres je suis Michael
Jackson dans ma tête je pense que je
danse mais de l'extérieur on dirait une
crise d'épilepsie
aujourd'hui c'est génial aussi à Pierre
Arditi ah bah oui quand même Pierre
Arditi pierre de César un Molière un 7
d'or chevalier de la Légion d'Honneur
officier de leur nationale du Mérite
bravo bon par contre il vous reste que
trois points sur votre permis donc ça
sert à rien de se répéter non plus
génial avec Pierre c'est qu'il a pas
bougé physiquement c'est vrai on a
toujours connu vieux
d'ailleurs pour tous ceux qui pensent
que vous avez jamais été jeune vous avez
pas une peinture de vous ado un truc non
celui-ci ma mission comme toutes les
semaines posez les questions trop con
que Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser alors Ariane vous êtes belle drôle
et en plus vous faites de la boxe thaï
vous savez que pour Joey Starr vous êtes
la famille
c'est vrai que si on vous retire votre
banane vous êtes le sosie de Patrick
Timsit il paraît et dans un article
pierre j'ai découvert que votre femme
Évelyne Bouix va au cinéma 6 fois par
semaine à 10 euros la place acheter un
cinéma franchement ça ira beaucoup plus
vite ça va bien ça va Thierry ça va mais
des stagiaires j'en ai connu des plus
rapides je suis désolé je suis désolé
vous avez vu d'ailleurs cette semaine ce
qui s'est passé les employés d'Air
France là qui ils étaient en colère du
coup ils ont mis le DRH à poil avec les
bruits de couloir que j'entends sur vous
Thierry j'espère que vous êtes naturiste
alors
Thierry il est là Jean Gabin non parce
que tout à l'heure vous me demandiez où
était la [__] de rappeur donc voilà
alors Jean Gabin votre prénom c'est
Charlène bouche vous avez choisi votre
nom de scène par rapport à l'acteur qui
a marqué votre adolescence moi si
j'avais fait pareil je serai Clara
Morgane
alors Jean Gabin quand il était jeune il
avait un groupe qui s'appelait les
requins vicieux ils avaient deux
passions dans la vie le hip-hop est
dépouillé les mecs comme moi d'ailleurs
c'est marrant parce que mon père il vous
avait croisé dans une soirée la main
jaune en 84 et du coup il me demande si
vous comptiez lui rendre sa doudoune
Chevignon et
c'est sur cette badminton
michel Cymes l'humoriste qui a fait
médecine pour déconner
c'est quand même le docteur tout le
monde aimerait avoir un médecin qui
t'annonce une maladie grave avec une
blague d'ailleurs est-ce que vous
connaissez là la différence entre un
cancer et la sodomie alors même si les
deux sont douloureux la sodomie elle ne
fait pas perdre ses cheveux c'est le
gros
alors Valérie Pécresse il paraît qu'en
2010 Patrick Buisson aurait dit à
Nicolas Sarkozy qu'il ne fallait pas
vous nommer au ministère de la justice
parce que vous étiez trop glamour voilà
donc on fait un gros bisou à Michaël
Alliot-Marie qui a eu le poste à votre
place
Valérie Pécresse j'ai lu que vous voulez
retirer la nationalité française
automatique alors je cite à 18 ans il
faut faire une demande de nationalité et
ensuite on vérifie que le jeûne adhère
aux principes républicains alors du coup
comment on procède parce que ça veut
dire que si on doit par exemple à
l'examen réciter la Marseillaise moi
j'ai plus la nationalité et au passage
on a pu d'équipe de foot voilà je
préfère le et honnêtement moi à 18 ans
le seul moment où j'étais fier de
brandir ma carte d'identité c'était au
caissier du Franprix pour acheter des
bières
maintenant mesdames et ce je suis ici
pour vous poser les questions trop con
que Thierry ici présent n'a pas voulu
vous poser alors Valérie Pécresse vous
avez aucune casserole aucune mise en
examen aucun dérapage à votre actif
qu'est-ce que vous foutez chez
républicain
même si Jean gamin à propos de votre
livre vous avez tweeté ce bouquin c'est
comme à marmot je me suis senti comme
une fouf 9 mois en couveuse et il est
sorti à terme alors j'ai envie de vous
demander comment va votre ouf ben
justement je vais bientôt 50 berges il
va falloir que je subisse une coloscopie
alors savoir si je dois
c'est un peu derrière la fouf ok ok
[Applaudissements]
et Michel Cymes on connaît votre passion
pour les blagues un peu coquines du coup
je vous demande pas quel est votre
solution pour reboucher le trou de la
Sécu non ça va très bonne journée
mon café [__] c'est long
ça va Thierry merci merci mon petit cœur
il est froid il est froid
de l'émission de la semaine dernière
beaucoup de gens se sont pleins qu'on
reçoit michel Cymes qu'on voit déjà
beaucoup à la télévision vraiment désolé
cette semaine rien à voir en soi Michel
Drucker
sur Twitter aussi beaucoup de gens ont
pris au premier degré les 22 michel
Cymes sur Nagui alors je vous rassure
ils sont copains si mais il a dit que
Nagui il est chiant il a le melon c'est
pas vrai bien entendu il a dit aussi
Nagui il y a que lui qui comprend ses
blagues
bon ça par contre c'était vrai
[Applaudissements]
alors ce soir on a un magnifique plateau
c'est incroyable ce soir c'est bien
non ce qui est très bien c'est que tout
le monde est resté jeune ça c'est
incroyable Michel Drucker il est resté
jeune grâce au vélo Jean-Michel Jarre il
est resté jeune grâce au voyage Enrico
Macias grâce à la musique et Thierry
Ardisson grâce à sa maquilleuse non
c'est quand même
non ce qui est fou c'est qu'on vous a
tous connu il y a 30 ans avec la même
tête moi je me mets à la place d'un mec
qui sort aujourd'hui d'un coma de 20 ans
j'étais Isaac il y a le conflit
israélo-palestinien sur TF1 sur France 3
il y a question pour un champion là il
regarde Ardisson il y a Enrico Macias
Jean-Michel Jarre et Michel Drucker pour
lui il a juste fait une sieste de deux
heures
[Applaudissements]
Michel Drucker Michel nous adore je vous
ai vu samedi dernier chez Laurent
Ruquier vous avez traité un journaliste
de gros con Michel il se lâche enfin le
problème c'est comme ça fait 73 ans qui
se retient le gros con de la semaine
dernière c'était juste l'apéritif
regardez l'émission jusqu'au bout parce
qu'à mon avis dans 10 minutes il y a un
fils de [__] qui va partir
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Michel Jarre Jean-Michel Jarre
c'est la classe dans les années 70-80
vous étiez considéré comme l'incarnation
du futur au même titre que les Bogdanov
voilà alors c'est sûr que quand on les
voit on se dit que le futur a priori
c'était pas la chirurgie esthétique ça
c'est certain
mais bravo Jean-Michel grâce à au
million de gens qui sont venus voir vos
concerts vous êtes rentrés quatre fois
dans le Guinness Book alors il est page
42 entre le mec qui jette des alliés
avec son nez celui qui soulève des
parpaings avec ses testicules
alors ici mesdames et messieurs ma
mission est de poser les questions trop
con que Thierry Ardisson ici présent n'a
pas voulu vous poser première question
Jean-Michel Jarre David Guetta vous
considère comme son père spirituel vous
avez jamais pensé à l'avortement
spirituel
inamoja vous êtes chanteuse mannequin
actrice bref vous savez que si votre
album marche pas vous pouvez toujours
être fan de Nicolas Sarkozy le gros
avantage
Enrico Macias alors lorsque vous
chantiez en 2007 à quels sont jolies les
filles de Sarkozy vous pensiez pas
Nadine Morano j'espère
[Applaudissements]
et pour terminer Michel Drucker vous
avez été élu personnalité la plus
emblématique du PAV depuis 1950 devant
les 11 vitrines Jacques Martin et guilux
c'était quoi le critère pour gagner
c'était le talent ou être en vie
qu'est-ce qu'il y a c'est un
coca-censure et puis voilà
ça va tout le monde va bien tout le
monde va bien bon cool petit débrief de
la semaine dernière Thierry vous avez
pleuré lors de la dernière mission en
écoutant une chanson de Enrico Macias
moi aussi ça me fait toujours le même
effet quand j'entends le mendiant de
l'amour j'ai envie de chialer pas pour
les mêmes raisons que vous mais voilà
alors qu'on regarde le plateau ce soir
c'est bien c'est beau c'est vrai bon
alors le problème c'est qu'on sait pas
si c'est une émission de télé ou un
congrès de dentiste tellement il y a
dedans blanche mais c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
Frédéric Lopez c'est la classe il a
inventé plein de super concepts
d'émission Rendez-vous en terre inconnue
c'est lui tu sais tu prends une star et
tu l'emmènes dans un pays où il voulait
pas aller à la base il a fait avec
Arthur Frédéric il emmenait au Pérou en
Belgique c'est pas de sa faute mais
alors le rituel c'est de bander les yeux
de la star à l'aéroport pour cacher la
destination bon sauf avec Gilbert
Montagné forcément non non mais à la
place il lui avait bouché le nez et
non d'ailleurs et si jamais vous voulez
faire rendez-vous en terre inconnue avec
Thierry lui bandez pas les yeux parce
que ça va lui rappeler ces soirées aux
chandelles ça va
alors Frédéric Lopez vous venez nous
voir pour votre nouvelle émission sur
France 2 où il y aura des humoristes 4
invités
1 2 3 4 un groupe de musique
comment ça se passe Thierry vous allez
vous laisser marcher sur les couilles
jusqu'au bout de l'émission non on
attend d'habitude
Natacha Polony aussi c'est beau c'est
une rousse avec un air Street habillé en
cuir et qui est droite bref la fille
caché de Mylène Farmer et d'Alain Juppé
[Applaudissements]
alors Natacha vous allez présenter une
nouvelle émission sur Paris Première
polonium que vous enregistrez au bain
Thierry à l'époque bain de minuit
c'était au bain douche j'appelle
l'avocat tout de suite ou comment ça se
passe au niveau des droits des missions
[__] alors votre marine natacha est
critique gastronomie et j'ai lu quelque
part que dans votre propre maison ne
vous n'avez pas le droit de pénétrer
dans votre propre cuisine c'est pas la
mienne d'ailleurs c'est ça cuisine du
coup Frédéric voulait pas faire un
terrain connu chez mobalpike Natacha
Christophe Beaugrand Christophe
Beaugrand vous êtes l'animateur de
Secret Story cristaux vous avez dit
présenter Secret Story c'était votre vœu
le plus cher j'ai dit ça oui
alors raconte vraiment
c'est quoi votre vol plus pourri
[Applaudissements]
alors d'ailleurs Thierry vous pourriez
participer Secret Story bah ouais j'ai
trouvé un secret déjà c'est je fais les
meilleures audiences de Canal+ et
personne ne le sait
mesdames et messieurs ma mission ici est
de poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser on va commencer avec Frédéric
Lopez alors Frédéric dans votre jeunesse
vous avez déménagé pas moins de 19 fois
est-ce que vous savez qu'il y a des
gitans beaucoup plus sédentaires que
vous
[Applaudissements]
Christophe Beaugrand vous avez participé
à l'émission Splash sur TF1 c'était quoi
le plus dur le plongeon de 10 mètres ou
se balader en slip devant 5 millions de
gens acheter un maillot large quand même
oh mais il y avait une couille qui
dépassait
Natacha Polony alors Natacha aux avis
déjà atteint votre taille adulte à l'âge
de 12 ans vous avez d'autres points
communs avec Mimi Mathy ou pas
bon Thierry j'y vais
franchement je pense qu'on le retrouvera
la semaine prochaine
bah alors mon pote qu'est-ce que tu fous
là
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
stagiaire c'est plus que c'était je suis
désolé je fais juste une petite
parenthèse qui a Mathieu si tu peux me
signer ça tout de suite s'il te plaît
voilà parce que vu qu'il vient tous les
trois mois lui a fait un contrat parce
que
j'ai envie d'être payé moi maintenant
c'est cool merci c'est cool hop ça c'est
fait c'est bien ça va passer à la compta
alors que vous l'aurez remarqué Thierry
déjà un très très beau plateau ce soir
on a invité qui est beaucoup plus sexy
que les trois autres c'est pas lui que
j'ai commencé bah tu m'as déni en
bonsoir
non mais je vais être très honnête avec
les téléspectateurs Mathieu c'est un
copain j'ai fait sa première partie
pendant un an dans toute la France on a
fait toutes les plus belles villes et
puis on a fait aussi Montceau-les-Mines
Sedan et Oyonnax autant en termes de
filles et drogue la tournée elle a été
plutôt tranquille par contre en terme de
charcuterie et de vin j'ai fait le
calcul on a buté 132 cochons et on a tué
24 hectares de vigne c'est vrai on va
aller voir son spectacle il joue à Paris
très bientôt il est très très marrant
Mathieu Madénian au grand point virgule
du jeudi voilà et bien c'est bien petit
con
en plus Mathieu il est supporté à de
l'OM ce qui fait qu'on a deux fans de
ballons autour de du plateau ce soir un
ballon de foot et un ballon de rouge
Eddy Mitchell bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
vraiment je vais être très honnête je
suis très ému parce que Eddy Mitchell je
l'adore alors je sais que je dis ça
toutes les semaines mais là je le pense
vraiment parce que Eddy Mitchell c'est
la classe c'est l'un des rares qui
arrivent à faire swinguer la langue
française avec Michel Jonas et Franck
Ribéry aussi mais non mais d'ailleurs
faut que vous m'expliquez un truc
monsieur Eddy parce que voilà je suis
fan et en fait vous avez bercé mon
adolescence mon père il mettait toujours
vos CD dans la voiture et en 2011 vous
avez annoncé vous arrêtez la carrière et
en 2013 vous avez fait Bercy avec du
tronc et Johnny du coup bah moi j'ai
foncé j'ai acheté des places voilà
pensant vous voir pour la dernière fois
et là vous refaites des concerts au
Palais des sports du coup j'ai racheté
des places jusqu'à quand vous allez nous
[__] comme ça
j'avais dit et je me tiens que je ne
faisais plus de tourner d'accord j'avais
parlé de Paris cristina Cordula je vous
dis ma copine vous adore voilà moi le
seul truc qui me gêne c'est vos grosses
boucles d'oreilles voilà pourquoi c'est
plus des boucles d'oreilles c'est des
cerceaux à chaque fois je me dis elles
vont s'enflammer il y a un lion qui va
aller traverser
l'émission qui vous a rendu célèbre
c'est les reines du shopping c'est une
émission de science-fiction parce qu'en
fait les candidates elles ont trois
heures pour trouver une tenue se faire
coiffer se faire maquiller trois heures
c'est la durée que ma copine mais pour
juste trouver cette nuit et encore chez
nous dans notre propre maison avec les
vêtements
non mais moi ce que ce que j'aime
beaucoup dans les reines du shopping
c'est qu'il y a des thèmes tu sais il y
a par exemple séduisant en cuir dîner à
la table du capitaine convocation chez
le proviseur on dirait titre porno des
cassettes de mon père c'est
ici pour vous poser les questions trop
con que Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu
vous poser Mathieu vanenian vous avez
commencé dans la série indien une fille
mais vous voyez toujours de dos ça fait
quoi d'avoir le même début de carrière
que Clara Morgane
tu es vraiment une merde mais je t'aime
Eddy Mitchell et dit c'est vrai qu'à la
base la chanson couleur menthe à l'eau
elle devait s'appeler couleur jet 27
Cordula vous faites partie de l'équipe
de Laurent Ruquier dans les grosses
têtes du coup Christine Bravo c'est quoi
c'est un relooking ou un ravalement qui
lui faut
c'est méchant
depuis ton succès de la semaine dernière
à la place de Guillaume maintenant le
droit à une musique d'entrée
c'est génial mec alors je m'emballe pas
non plus parce que tout à l'heure il y a
eu la répartition des Loges ils m'ont
mis dans les chiottes donc c'est pas
gagné préciser petit débrief de
l'émission de la semaine dernière
Thierry gros gros buzz Christina Cordula
annoncé que par amour pour son mari
était prête à aller dans un club échangé
en plus ça valait dans un club
échangiste avec son mari c'est débile
oui c'est comme aller le cheval à la
boulangerie qui sont pas c'est pas de
sens
alors très très beau plateau ce soir
Thierry on reçoit laurent Ournac laurent
Ournac c'est l'homme qui a prouvé à tes
fins qu'on pouvait perdre du poids sans
participer à Koh-Lanta
on va en parler 2 secondes c'est quand
même extraordinaire ce qui s'est passé
vous avez perdu 50 kg enfin perdu en
fait il vous en retirez un morceau de
l'estomac donc la formule exacte c'est
pas j'ai perdu 50 kg mais j'ai vidangé
50 kg
[Musique]
non mais c'est vrai d'ailleurs il y en a
qui fait la gueule c'est notre sosie
parce que le mec pendant 10 ans il a
bouffé de la merde là du coup il a été
obligé de se teindre les cheveux en rose
il fait sosie de Loana alors
[Applaudissements]
non
Zazie pour les impôts et vos parents
c'est Isabelle Marianne de Truchy de
Varenne voilà alors Zazie vous êtes
coach dans The Voice depuis deux ans et
vous avez déclaré avec Jennifer qui s'en
va je vais devoir porter plus de jupes
ou mettre un kilt à Garou alors je
préfère la première option parce que
Garou si on respecte les traditions du
kilt si tout est proportionné à savoir
il va faire peur aux gamins non mais
c'est vrai
Ahmed Sylla Ahmed Ahmed le grand public
vous avez découvert et qu'on demande
qu'à en rire et le tout petit public
vous a découvert avec l'Académie des
neufs sur NRJ12 non j'ai regardé une
émission c'était vachement bien et j'ai
fait [__] sans déconner Denis Fabre
est encore en vie j'étais pas au courant
non mais c'est vrai alors Ahmed vous
avez fait beaucoup de scènes ouvertes à
vos débuts alors j'explique au
téléspectateurs ce que c'est une scène
ouverte c'est le principe c'était debout
tu fais marer les gens sans être payé à
la fin c'est un petit peu comme un stage
chez Ardisson alors
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry n'a pas voulu vous poser on va
commencer avec Laurent ournat qui vous
avez une perte de poids impressionnante
du coup je vais vous poser la question
de tout le monde se pose vous avez perdu
de partout
non l'avantage quand on maigrit c'est
que tout ce qu'on perd on gagne ailleurs
non mais en terme de
[Applaudissements]
non non parce que tu vois maintenant
parce que non mais non pas comme ça on
l'appelle la bûche
Zazie Zazie avant tout le monde vous
appelez Zaz mais depuis que Zaz existe
on vous appelle comment Zaz la vraie
celle qui se douche
Ahmed Sylla alors Ahmed vous avez
déclaré que grâce à on demande qu'à en
rire vous avez pu tourner dans Alice
Nevers le juge est une femme si vous
aviez eu une bonne note vous auriez JO
dans quoi alors du coup
[Applaudissements]
un petit truc léger parfait les gars
nous entre noirs on se comprend alors
petit débrie de mission de la semaine
dernière Thierry bravo félicitations
semaine dernière record d'audience près
de 1 million 400000 et spectateurs c'est
énorme
surtout surtout avec en invité un ancien
gros une chanteuse à la retraite et un
mec avec une tâche sur le nez
c'était pas gagné à la base et puis vous
en avez parlé la semaine dernière
Thierry de la future édition de Mein
Kampf il y a laurent Ournac qui est
dégoûté parce qu'il voulait faire un
livre sur sa perte de poids qui voulait
appeler mon combat mais mon combat en
allemand c'est mannequin
très très beau plateau Thierry ce soir
on a on a Estelle Denis c'est la seule
femme de France qui est capable
d'expliquer un hors-jeu bravo non mais
c'est vrai non mais ce qui a bien c'est
qu'avec Estelle elle a prouvé qu'une
femme pouvait parler de foot sans dire à
chaque fin de phrase Yoann Gourcuff il
est trop beau et ça c'est bien alors
vous êtes aux commandes du nouvel
émission sur D8 qui s'appelle touche pas
à mon sport alors dans laquelle il y
aura une bande de chroniqueurs parmi eux
il y aura Raymond Domenech
encore un qui a couché pour avoir du
boulot
Estelle Estelle Denis en plus de touche
pas à mon sport sur D8 il y aura vis ma
vie sur NT1 qui va être diffusé aussi
alors vis ma vie je sais pas si vous
connaissez c'est cette émission qui
montre au chanteur Keen'V le métier de
boucher c'est à dire le métier qui va
retourner faire quand ça carrière sera
terminée
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Michel Apathie aussi après 12 ans
de bons et loyaux services sur RTL et
bien vous êtes fait remercier comme
Philippe Bouvard pourtant vous arriviez
encore à parler alors
vous avez quitté RTL pour Europe 1 vous
a quitté une radio de vieux pour une
radio de d'un peu moins vieux et non non
je rigole parce que moi aussi je suis
sur Europe 1 j'adore cette radio et
alors en Cabrol il y a Catherine Michel
cotta Philippe Gildas Jean-Pierre
bon effectivement de l'extérieur on
dirait un peu la maison de retraite du
PAF mais non mais c'est là où je me
rends compte que vous êtes beaucoup trop
jeune pour Europe 1 en fait vous avez 57
ans en fait vous êtes arrivés 10 ans
trop tôt Jean-Michel
François Damien je l'adore vraiment
François non mais sincèrement j'aime
beaucoup François vous êtes originaire
de Bruxelles hein ce qui fait que vous
avez un fort accent alors l'accent belge
de Bruxelles en fait c'est un mélange de
hockey et de glaire
c'est une sorte d'angine en fait voilà
et vous êtes fait connaître grâce à vos
caméras cachées alors malheureusement
vous pouvez plus en faire aujourd'hui
parce que les gens vous reconnaissent
vous avez exactement le même problème
que Benjamin Castaldi lui aussi peut
plus faire de télé parce que les gens le
reconnaissent et
ma mission mesdames et messieurs ici
c'est de poser les questions trop con
que Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
oui Estelle Denis Estelle vous avez
déclaré quand je perds au tennis j'ai
les larmes aux yeux et quand vous
regardez les replay de splatch ça vous
faites quoi alors
Jean-Michel vous avez déclaré c'est un
univers où il y a du charme de
l'irrationnel et de la solitude alors
vous parliez de la politique ou de la
masturbation
François Damiens vous avez tourné des
caméras cachées en Corse qu'est-ce qui
était le plus dur comprendre leur accent
ou rester en vie un restaurant
à tous pas de débrief de l'émission de
la semaine dernière parce que il y a pas
eu d'émission la semaine dernière à
cause des événements alors bien entendu
on a une grosse pensée pour pour toutes
les victimes ainsi que pour leur famille
et leurs proches mais bon comme il faut
qu'on continue à vivre je vais essayer
de très modestement de faire ce que je
sais de mieux apporter des cafés
ce soir un plateau de qualité Jean-Luc
Mélenchon alors Jean-Luc je sais pas
comment faire des blagues sur lui parce
que j'ai peur qu'il me gueule dessus en
même temps là où j'ai une chance de m'en
sortir c'est que je suis pas journaliste
vous savez que dans le Petit Larousse
illustré à côté du mot colère il y a
votre photo Jean-Luc alors pour ceux qui
ne connaîtraient pas Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il est très très à gauche voilà Jean-Luc
la seule fois de sa vie où il est passé
à droite c'était au volant d'une voiture
en Angleterre
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'aujourd'hui un mec qu'on
qualifie d'extrême gauche il y a 20 ans
c'était juste un socialiste en fait
effectivement le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui si la gauche c'est valse
c'est Macron tout le monde est extrême
gauche
Guillaume Durand Guillaume vous êtes à
l'antenne de Radio Classique la radio
préférée des salles d'attente de
médecins
alors sur l'antenne vos collègues sont
PPDA Claire Chazal Christian Morin en
fait c'est plus une radio sa maison de
retraite de TF1 Radio Classique un petit
peu
autant pour moi donc là c'est le
cimetière alors
vous avez vous avez votre émission aussi
sur TV5 Monde et selon un récent sondage
vous êtes l'animateur préféré des
Français à l'étranger qui sont bloqués à
l'hôtel à cause d'une tourista
[Applaudissements]
Dounia Bouzar bonsoir Dounia bonsoir
alors Dounia vous avez un papa maroco
algérien une maman d'origine corse et
italienne en fait vous êtes la tour de
Babel à vous toute seule
algero Marocco Italo Corse un conseil
vous prenez pas la tête avec Dounia
parce que vu ses origines elle doit
avoir un caractère de merde
alors
Dounia vous luttez pour pour que les
jeunes deviennent pas des djihadistes
alors un djihadiste qu'est-ce que c'est
et ben c'est un peu comme un critique
littéraire à la télé c'est juste un mec
qui lit des livres en diagonale
alors on a découvert qu'il y avait une
grosse filaire djihadiste en Belgique ou
en des comptes Thierry même les
kamikazes ils veulent payer moins
d'impôts
ma mission ici mesdames et messieurs
comme toutes les semaines c'est de poser
les questions trop con que Thierry
Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous poser
Guillaume Durand il y a peu de temps
vous avez clashé Stéphane Bern et sa
vision Rance de la culture alors le
clash Berne Durand c'est quoi c'est
c'est comme le clash Rohff Booba mais
par contre avec des brushings et des
vestes
Dounia Bouzar Dounia vous avez autour de
vous un protocole de sécurité très
stricte par exemple vous n'avez pas le
droit de vous faire livrer des paquets
mais du coup quand vous commandez
chinois livreur il arrive avec du riz
cantonais dans les poches
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Jean-Luc lors des
dernières élections présidentielles vous
avez terminé derrière Marine Le Pen
c'était quoi le pire c'était la défaite
ou la vue
[Applaudissements]
plateau incroyable Thierry ce soir on a
on a tout le lobby normand sur le
plateau Michel Onfray et Orelsan il
manque que Michel Drucker et un
camembert et on était au complet
Florence vous êtes la seule non normande
du plateau mais bon comme vous crachez
pas sur un petit calva on va dire que
vous êtes Normands aussi Florence
Foresti c'est la classe c'est la
patronne alors dans un article sur vous
j'ai lu Florence Foresti après 15 ans de
carrière et une grossesse elle est de
retour sur scène ah quand j'ai lu ça mon
côté féministe ne fait qu'un tour non
sans déconner c'est complètement débile
de dire après 15 ans de carrière une
grossesse est-ce qu'on dira à propos
d'un mec après 15 ans de carrière et
avoir lagué sa femme pour une team jeune
de 20 ans de moins que lui et ben il est
de retour sur scène et ben non on le
dirait pas alors Florence vous allez
animer les Césars alors vous nous direz
après mais je crois que tous ceux qu'on
présentait les Césars sont d'accord pour
dire que le meilleur moment et bah ça
reste le dîner aux Fouquet de ça près
Michel Onfray Michel Onfray c'est la
classe c'est le premier philosophe qu'on
reçoit de la saison à part Frédéric
Lopez je veux dire mais
alors Michel Onfray on a dit de vous
vous étiez islamophobe soutien de Marine
Le Pen et maintenant défenseur de daesh
voilà alors à tous les petits branleurs
qui nous regardent qui sont au lycée qui
disent moi plus tard je vais te
philosophe vous avez vu c'est quand même
beaucoup d'emmerdes donc si il est pas
finir comme lui bosser à l'école très
important
[Applaudissements]
pour votre dernier ouvrage vous avez
collaboré avec Mylène Farmer alors c'est
vrai qu'à la base on se dit Mylène
Farmer et Michel Onfray qui bossent
ensemble
c'est un peu comme Christine and the
Queen et Didier Barbelivien il y a un
truc qui déconne et puis en fait elle a
fait les dessins de votre livre alors
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
elle a fait des dessins très joyeux
plein de couleurs gris clair gris foncé
gris noir noir brillant noir mat c'était
très très bien c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai non à coup il y a eu un bleu foncé
alors
Orelsan Orelsan je le déteste non mais
vraiment pas ce que ma copine l'adore et
en fait elle vous trouve trop beau et
quand vous regarde à la télé elle a
dites-vous que vous aviez un petit côté
crade excitant alors je te jure que
c'est vrai moi du coup pour lui faire
plaisir j'ai essayé de pas me laver
pendant trois jours elle a juste trouvé
que j'avais un côté cratout courant
alors Orelsan pour les personnes qui
connaîtraient pas à la base il y a peur
mais maintenant il est comédien voilà
vous jouez dans un programme court sur
Canal+ qui s'appelle bloqué à l'origine
le titre c'était deux connards dans un
canapé mais c'était déjà le surnom que
donnait Thierry à Vivement dimanche donc
du coup ça
mesdames et messieurs ma mission ici est
de poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Michel Onfray et si vous pensez que que
le fait que vous ne croyez en rien est
un rapport avec le fait que vous viviez
en Normandie
Orelsan Orelsan en 1998 vous avez été
éboueur et aujourd'hui votre producteur
de spectacle s'appelle Olivier poubelle
non mais c'est vrai c'est parce que vous
croyez aussi du destin que vous avez
signé avec lui ou pas
Florence Foresti votre fille vous voit
partir travailler quand il fait nuit et
rentrer avec plein d'argent le matin
et c'est ce que vous faites dans la vie
votre fille ou pas
[Applaudissements]
bonne émission bon toi merci la semaine
dernière on se fait Michel Onfray qui a
beaucoup divisé sur les réseaux sociaux
il y a une moitié qui l'aimait pas trop
et l'autre moitié qui le détestait
non je rigole on embrasse Michel Onfray
d'ailleurs qui a décidé de se mettre en
retrait du paysage médiatique il a fermé
son compte Twitter mais bon s'il a fait
ses adieux comme Charles Aznavour il va
revenir dans deux semaines
très très beau plateau ce soir Thierry
Stéphane de Groodt c'est la classe on
vous compare à Raymond Devos c'est à
Pierre Desproges voilà moi on compare à
Jean Dujardin et à George Clooney non
mais c'est vrai bon parce que j'apporte
le café à Thierry donc ça compte pas
mais Stéphane de gros c'est la réussite
belge alors un Belge qu'est-ce que c'est
et bien c'est un chti intelligent parce
que quitte avoir le même climat de merde
le Belge lui paye moins d'impôts voilà
en plus c'est vrai que avant quand on
pensait un Belge on pensait à
Jean-Claude Van Damme mais quand il
parlait on comprenait rien à ce qu'il
disait alors que maintenant on a vous de
grotte on vous non plus on comprend rien
à ce que vous dites néanmoins c'est la
classe
[Applaudissements]
frérot Delavega ils sont énervants les
mecs ils sont beaux ils chantent bien
ils font de la guitare ils viennent du
Sud-Ouest sisters en gros Thierry c'est
quand même les mecs qui ont détestait
qu'on était au lycée on le répétera
jamais assez mais ce sont pas les frères
de la Vega très important le préciser
voilà en fait frérot de la Vegas c'est
vos noms de famille respectifs il y en a
un c'est Jérémy frérot et l'autre comme
son nom l'indique c'est Florian Garcia
alors non pour la petite histoire dites
moi si je me trompe mais je crois que ça
vient du du patron d'Universal Pascal
[__] parce que Florian Garcia Sergent
Garcia l'ennemis de Zorro Zoro qui
s'appelle don Diego dela Vega donc
frérot de l'avenir donc vous l'aurez
compris la drogue c'est mal voilà
[Applaudissements]
Laurence Boccolini Laurence vous
présenter Money Drop sur TF1 alors le
concept c'est 250000 € au liquide sur
une table une question 4 possibilités de
réponse et si la personne mise bien sur
la bonne réponse il repart avec l'argent
et si mise mal il repart sans argent et
avec sa femme donc c'est la double peine
tu imagines 250 000 euros en liquide
cache à gagner le mec qui gagne le
dictionnaire des synonymes ma question
pour un champion il doit être dégoûté
non en tout cas bravo vous faites un
carton à audience 4 millions de
téléspectateurs tous les soirs ça fait
une fois et demi de plus que Nagui deux
fois et demi de plus canona 4 fois plus
que c'est à vous et autant que le Grand
Journal voilà entre 19h02 et 19h03 sur
les CSP + borgne habitant
Clermont-Ferrand et entendu
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Stéphane de Groodt Stéphane vous avez un
pied à Paris pour le travail et un pied
à Bruxelles pour la vie ça veut dire que
vous avez la moitié du temps les
couilles à Maubeuge ou pas
alors Jérémy c'est un secret pour pour
personne maintenant vous êtes en couple
avec Laure Manaudou Florian comment vous
l'avez découvert il sentait le chlore
ça fait quoi de sortir avec une retraite
maintenant
couche à 18h Laurence Boccolini vous
êtes fait tatouer dans le cou qui se mis
si vous faites un tatouage dans le bas
du dos ça sera quoi alors
merci beaucoup
alors ce week-end c'est le second tour
des élections régionales donc on n'a pas
le droit de parler de politique
et bon les Français ils sont débiles
quand même vous avez vu ce qu'ils ont
fait vous avez vu pour qu'ils ont voté
réveillez-vous vous pouvez pas faire ça
voilà Thierry ils ont fait gagner un
chien une gamine Incroyable Talent sur
M6 on connaît je pense qu'il faudrait
retirer le droit de vote à ces gens là
alors non oui bonsoir alors Thierry vu
que Nora est venu il y a 10 mois pour
exactement la même promo bah du coup
j'ai ressorti vos vieilles fiches voilà
hop comme ça c'est les mêmes questions
j'en ai rajouté une petite au cas où
voilà ça fait plaisir ce spectacle ça
cartonne toujours voilà comme ça
on s'emmerde pas
alors selon Marie-Claire vous faites
partie des 10 femmes les plus drôles de
France bravo voilà je savais pas qu'il y
en avait 10 mais non je sais que c'est
misogyne mais c'est vrai que
généralement quand on dit d'une fille
qu'elle est marrante honnêtement il y a
quand même 9 chances sur 10 pour que ça
soit un tronc blond non mais c'est vrai
Jean-Luc Lemoine alors Jean-Luc Thierry
en fait vu qu'il est venu il y a 9 mois
pour exactement la même promo du coup
voilà je ressors les vieilles fiches
aussi on s'emmer un point
hop alors Cyril Hanouna toujours sympa
ça c'est fait alors Jean-Luc je l'adore
dans Touche pas à mon poste il fait la
rubrique des 4/3 alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas en fait ils récupèrent
les images que personne ne voit pendant
la pub et il les montre à l'antenne
alors le terme technique c'est diffuser
des offres ou alors faire un coup de
[__] c'est au choix non mais c'est une
idée géniale les Katia moi c'est pas que
je veux pas le faire c'est que je peux
pas si je diffuse non mais non si je
diffuse ce qui se passe pendant les pubs
les téléspectateurs vont être super
déçus ça il pense que Ardisson c'est sex
drogue et rock'n'roll alors qu'il y a
pas de rock'n'roll voilà
remarqué il y a pas beaucoup de sexe non
plus mais
non mais c'est vrai
Frédéric Beigbeder bonsoir alors
Frédéric vous dirigez le magazine Lui
voilà tenez je me permets c'est un petit
CV si jamais voilà parce que voilà si
vous cherchez un stagiaire qui est moi
je serais ravi de me bosser avec vous et
[Applaudissements]
voilà
je vous la donne au cas où c'est ma
lettre de motivation voilà tenez
c'est plutôt des stagiaires de sexe
féminin en général c'est pas grave comme
par hasard
Frédéric j'ai une très très bonne
nouvelle pour certains et une mauvaise
pour vous voilà vous êtes papa depuis un
mois voilà toutes ces nuits blanches que
vous avez passé en boîte de nuit en fait
c'était juste pour vous préparer la
paternité puis depuis que vous avez une
petite fille maintenant les rôles sont
inversés c'est vous qui vous faites
vomir dessus
prendre Olivier Giesbert tu viens donc
nous voir pour pour son film sur Chirac
mais il y a un petit débat juste après
donc c'est quoi le débat pour ou contre
l'euthanasie ça je sais pas drôle non
c'est vrai juste un truc il y a un truc
que je comprends pas il y a 15 jours
vous avez fait un documentaire sur les
bêtes d'abattoir aujourd'hui vous venez
de faire un documentaire sur Jacques
Chirac non mais c'est bien c'est un
documentaire sur la viande et un autre
sur les légumes ça c'est cool
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser Nora Hamzaoui Nora vous êtes
d'origine syrienne du coup l'été vous
partez quand même en vacances au bled ou
pas
Franz Olivier Giesbert tous les anciens
présidents étaient des hommes à femmes
Mitterrand Chirac Sarkozy même Hollande
alors pourquoi Alain Juppé s'acharne
encore
on est souvent surpris quand on suit les
choses de près en se sent surpris des
gens ont pensé pas qu'il y avait des
histoires il y en a quand même
dossier
je ne suis pas la crainte tout est là on
allait super en train de le balancer je
vous souhaite une excellente émission
bon courage ça va tout le monde va bien
bonsoir alors là voilà bravo Thierry
parce que là le plateau il a de la
gueule voilà Rohff Baffie on a très
jolie fille aussi Virginie Efira
Géraldine Nakache tu as eu de la chance
parce que la semaine dernière il y avait
une brune et une blonde aussi mais
c'était Giesbert ça avait pas la même
gueule quand même
alors Virginie et Géraldine vous jouez
deux demi-sœurs dans le film et ta soeur
de Marion Vernoux alors c'est dommage
que ça soit pas dans un film d'abdilatif
qui est chiche parce que vous auriez
toujours été demi-soeur mais lesbiennes
et incestueuse et là c'était un César
assuré pour vous deux et ta soeur c'est
le remake français de ma meilleure amie
sa sœur et moi on aime bien faire des
remakes en France et on avait fait
Ocean's eleven's en français ça donnait
cash avec Jean Dujardin Fast and Furious
ça donnait les clés de bagnoles Laurent
Baffie
je suis très impressionné d'être à côté
de lui c'est vrai je suis un petit peu
comme le pape devant Jésus ou Alain
Delon devant Alain Delon je suis très
impressionné non mais c'est vrai c'est
le patron c'est le sniper tireur d'élite
jamais de sommation toujours entre les
deux yeux c'est non mais c'est là c'est
notre meilleur soldat tu commences une
phrase il a terminé c'est l'histoire
d'une [__] et d'un chameau vas-y Laurent
à toi
[Musique]
Ardisson et Baffie réunis en plus un peu
les Peter et Stone de la télé c'est vrai
besoin de rien envie d'une vanne et
alors toute la Dream te met là il manque
juste Corti alors c'est pas qu'il a pas
oui exactement le juge d'application des
peines n'a pas voulu qu'il vienne voilà
exactement
Laurent vous venez pour un livre où vous
avez fait plus de 1800 anagrammes et
d'ailleurs vous avez été accusé de
plagiat par Raphaël Enthoven il vous
accuse d'avoir repris plus de 40
anagrammes d'un autre livre 40 sur 1800
non mais 40 sur 1800 ont marqué c'était
quand même plus rapide de compter les
anagrammes en commun que les ex de son
ex Carla Bruni donc c'est logique
[Musique]
aller à mon tour tu es en plagi pas une
anagramme quand on cherche on trouve
alors que Camille oui on peut jouer
il m'a fait aimer le rap c'est le
rappeur en activité qui a vendu le plus
d'album en France près de 20 ans de
carrière 2 millions 2 millions d'albums
pas parce que je vais t'éclater
[Applaudissements]
après
c'est un nos meilleurs rappeurs selon
Skyrock c'est une petite baltringue
selon Booba alors juste pour expliquer
aux téléspectateurs ça fait trois ans
que vous êtes en clash avec Booba c'est
un autre rappeur par exemple pour
resituer pour mes grands-parents qui qui
regardent et qui comprennent bien c'est
un peu comme si Marcel Amont était en
guerre avec lui au frais voilà
c'est devenu un youtubeur il fait des
vidéos sur sa vie un petit peu comme
Norman fait des vidéos il fait des
vidéos sur ses ex avec son chat au Rohff
aussi avec ses expériences de vie à lui
aussi comment couper son bracelet
électronique la vie après la tôle
ne lève pas trop quand même je sens
qu'il y a une tension pas peur
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson ici présent n'a pas
voulu vous poser Géraldine Nakache
c'était quoi le plus dur dans le film
jouant en Bretagne en plein hiver ou
faire croire que vous êtes sœur avec du
Virginie
vous avez déclaré dans vos chansons ben
voilà vous parlez de la rue de la
famille des sentiments de l'amitié ça
fait quoi d'avoir les mêmes sujets que
Louane
Thierry juillet
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu